I'm exactly thirty miles away from the
intersection of Beverly Boulevard and
Northland Cienega Boulevard in downtown
Los Angeles this is part of the boundary
of the studio zone a 30 mile circle that
sweeps through Southern California
how much explains why a lot of planets
in science fiction look kind of the same
so if I was filming a movie and I asked
my cast and crew to meet me here outside
the zone I'd have to pay them for their
time and mileage getting to the location
but if I just walk a few paces this way
inside the studio zone then cast and
crew get paid from when they arrive here
from their cult I'm filming inside the
zone is significantly cheaper the
headquarters are pretty much all the
movie studios are inside the zone and so
on a lot of places that you'll have seen
in film and television Griffith Park
and Bronson Canyon are well within the
zone close to the center of Hollywood so
that's where Adam West bat cave was
along with where the walls fell for
Captain Picard I'm along with well
pretty much any American TV show that's
ever needed that sort of landscape and
Vasquez rocks which have been used in so
many TV shows films and music videos
that there is a separate Wikipedia page
just listing them it's conveniently 29
miles from the center of the zone if
those rocks were slightly further away
from Hollywood then who knows perhaps
Bill and Ted would have been killed by
their evil robot doubles somewhere else
why 30 miles Union rules Hollywood is a
Union town and long ago it was
negotiated that 30 miles was local and
anything outside wasn't presumably after
many many disagreements going back and
forth between union reps and the studios
now exceptions have been added over time
the rules are complicated and I couldn't
explain them all if I tried production
coordinators generally have that job but
in summary this 30 mile zone this TMZ
and yes that's where the gossip site got
its name from this border is why
sometimes it looks like the clearer the
enterprise are boldly going where quite
a lot of people have gone before
Oh
[Music]
you